Ang sample-based quantum diagonalization method o SQD ay isang quantum-classical hybrid algorithm tulad ng Krylov
quantum diagonalization KQD tulad ng VQE at marami pang iba. Sa paggamit ng mga ganitong hybrid
algorithm, makapagtutulong kung isipin kung saan ginagamit ng bawat algorithm ang quantum at classical computing. Alalahanin na ang VQE ay lumilikha ng mga estado sa isang quantum
circuit gamit ang mga parameter na na-optimize nang klasikal. Sa kasong iyon, ang estado mismo ay nasa quantum computer. Kahit
ang pagkuha ng target na estado ay isang proseso na pinagsama ang classical at quantum computing.
Ang expectation value ng operator ay kinakalkula gamit ang quantum measurements.
Ngunit kailangan din ng ilang klasikal na pagsasama ng mga termino.
Sa kaibahan, ginagamit ng SQD ang quantum computer para makabuo ng kapaki-pakinabang na subspace kung saan maaaring i-project ang Hamiltonian o iba pang operator.
Ang Hamiltonian ay dina-diagonalize nang ganap na klasikal para mahanap ang target na estado. Ipagpalagay na mayroon kaming
problemang may kaugnayan sa agham o industriya na maaaring gawin bilang isang eigen solver problem sa isang matrix ng n rows at
n columns. Ipagpalagay pa na ang n ay sapat na malaki para ang eksaktong klasikal na diagonalization ay hindi isang opsyon. Malinaw na
magiging kapaki-pakinabang na bawasan ang mga dimensyon ng aming matrix habang pinapanatili ang lahat ng nauugnay na katangian ng ground state. Totoo, iyan ang
layunin ng maraming approximate eigen solver approach, kabilang ang klasikal na krylov methods. Ipagpalagay nating alam namin ang sapat tungkol sa aming problema para makagawa ng
makatwirang mabuting hula tungkol sa anyo ng ground state, ngunit hindi sapat para malutas ang problema nang buo. Sa
kasong iyon, maaari kaming gumawa ng maraming sukat ng aming magandang approximation ng target ground state. Ang mga resulta ng mga
sukat na ito ay nagbibigay sa amin ng subspace ng mga computational basis state na naglalaman ng lahat ng nauugnay na bahagi ng aming
ground state. Ang pag-project sa subspace na iyon ay magbubunga ng mas maliit na matrix na naglalaman pa rin ng mga nauugnay na degree
of freedom. Ang workflow para dito ay ang sumusunod. Magsimula ka sa pagpili ng mabuting
ansatz. Mas tiyak, pumili ng ansatz na ang support ay nagtutugma sa support ng target na estado. Tatalakayin natin nang eksakto kung ano ang
ibig sabihin nito. Susunod, sukatin ang estado sa computational basis gaya ng ginagawa sa sampler primitive.
Pagkatapos, gamitin ang mga resulta ng sampling para tukuyin ang subspace na naglalaman ng ground state.
Pagkatapos, i-project ang iyong matrix sa subspace na iyon. Sa wakas, i-diagonalize ang mas maliit na projected matrix nang klasikal.
Suriin natin ang bawat isa sa mga hakbang na ito, na espesyal na nagbibigay-pansin sa pagtukoy ng subspace.
Sa buong quantum computing, ang pagpili ng mabuting ansatz ay palaging mahalaga. Sa kaso ng SQD, ang iyong pagpili ng ansatz
ang magtatakda kung aling mga computational basis state ang maaaring masukat sa sampling.
Ang tunay na ground state ay maaaring ipahayag bilang superposition ng ilang subset ng mga computational basis state. Ang subset na iyon
ay tinatawag na support ng ground state. Para makakuha ng magandang pagtatantya ng iyong ground state at ng enerhiya nito, ang iyong ansatz
ay dapat may hindi zero na projection sa mga computational basis state sa support ng ground state.
Ang diagram na ito ay kumakatawan sa espasyong sinasagnan ng lahat ng posibleng estado sa bilang ng mga qubit na ginagamit. Gusto namin ng
ansatz na ang support ay naglalaman ng support ng tunay na ground state.
Isaalang-alang ang isang napakaliit na halimbawa ng sistema na may ground state na s ground ay 8 *
estado 1 0 0 dagdag 6 * ang estado 001.
Ito ay may support na gawa sa dalawang vector na 1 0 0 at 0 1. Sabihin nating ang ansatz ay may anyo na ANSATZ 1 ay A beses
ang estado 1 0 0 dagdag B * ang estado 0 1 0 dagdag C * ang estado 001. Para ang
support nito ay ang set ng tatlong vector na 1 0 0, 1 0 at 0 0 1, isang superset ng
support ng ground state. Ito ay isang mabuting ansatz.
Ngayon isipin na pinili natin ang ansatz na may anyo na ANSATZ 2 ay a *
estado 1 1 0 dagdag b * ang estado 011.
Ito ay may support na gawa sa dalawang vector na 11 1 0 at 011 na walang pagkakatulad sa support ng ground
state. Ito ay isang masamang ansatz.
Pansinin na hindi natin kinakailangang kailangan ang ansatz na maging magandang approximation ng ground state. Ang ansatz ay maaaring
may mas malaking support o ang mga coefficient ay maaaring ibang-iba sa ansatz at sa tunay na ground state at gumagana pa rin nang maayos.
Sa yugtong ito, ginamit namin ang isang maayos na motivated na ansatz para mapagisipan ng quantum computer ang estado na katulad ng aming target
estado. Ipinakita dito ang unitary coupled cluster o UCJ ansatz na napaka-kapaki-pakinabang sa quantum chemistry.
Ngayon gusto naming sukatin ang estado ng sistema na nakakakuha ng mga bitstring na naglalarawan ng collapsed na estado ng bawat
qubit. Alalahanin na ang Hamiltonian estimation gaya ng sa VQE ay nangangailangan ng maraming quantum measurements. Ito ay bahagyang dahil sa
pagbabawas ng kawalan ng katiyakan at bahagyang dahil sa bilang ng mga grupo ng commuting Pauli na bumubuo ng Hamiltonian.
Sa mga sampling method, kailangan mo pa rin ng maraming sukat, ngunit naiiba ang mga dahilan. Ngayon, kailangan namin ng maraming sukat para epektibong i-sample ang
maraming computational basis state na kasangkot sa mga highly entangled quantum state. Sa SQD, ang mga na-sample na bitstring ay tumutugma
sa mga configuration ng na-simulate na sistema. Kung ang sistema na pinag-aaralan ay napapailalim sa mga ganap na hadlang tulad ng
mga batas ng konserbasyon sa pisika o chemistry, karamihan sa mga nasukat na estado ay magiging valid. Ngunit ilang na-sample na
bitstring ay tumutugma sa mga invalid o hindi pisikal na configuration dahil sa ingay at mga error. Isang proseso na tinatawag na
configuration recovery ay naglalayong pinuhin ang mga ingay na sample na ito sa isang set ng mas tumpak na configuration.
Ang prosesong ito ay kinabibilangan ng paglikha ng mga bagong configuration sa pamamagitan ng probabilistikong pag-flip ng mga indibidwal na bit batay sa
average na orbital occupancy at kilalang bilang ng particle.
Ang mga pinong configuration ay ginagamit pagkatapos para sumaklob sa mga subspace para sa Hamiltonian projection at diagonalization,
na paulit-ulit na nagpapabuti ng fidelity ng representasyon ng quantum state.
Tingnan natin ang isang napakaliit na halimbawa ng configuration recovery para maunawaan ang kahulugan nito. Ipagpalagay na susukat kami ng
quantum system na may apat na qubit na kumakatawan sa apat na molecular orbital at nakuha ang mga sumusunod na bitstring mula sa
quantum processor. Ang bawat bitstring ay kumakatawan sa occupancy ng isang orbital. Isa para sa
occupied, zero para sa unoccupied. Ginagamit ng Qiskit ang notasyon kung saan ang pinaka-mababa na significant qubit ay nasa kanan.
Halimbawa, ang 1 0 1 0 ay nagpapahiwatig na ang mga orbital 1 at tatlo ay occupied. Ang mga
sukat na ito ay pinili para sa mga pedagogical na dahilan lamang. Ang mga resultang occupancy ay maaaring hindi tumugma sa isang pisikal na sistema. Sa mga pisikal na konteksto, madalas
na ang sistema ay may kilalang kabuuang bilang ng mga particle. Maaari ding may iba pang mga batas ng konserbasyon na
maaaring gamitin mo para matukoy ang pagiging pisikal ng isang nasukat na estado. Para manatiling kongkreto, ipagpalagay nating ang aming sistema ay
kilala na may kabuuang bilang ng particle na n= 2. Sinasabi nito sa amin ang kabuuang bilang ng mga isa na dapat lumabas sa aming label ng estado
na tinatawag na Hamming weight constraint.
Gayunpaman, ang ilang nasukat na configuration ay lumalabag sa hadlang na ito. Ang estado 1 0 1 0 ay pisikal na valid. Ngunit ang estado 1 1
1 0 ay may masyadong maraming particle at ang estado ng lahat ng zero ay may masyadong kaunting particle. Zero
sa katunayan. Ang mga paglabag na ito ay maaaring dahil sa ingay sa sistema o mga error sa sukat. Kailangan namin ng paraan para bumalik
sa mga configuration na may katuturang pisikal kahit sa isang approximate na paraan.
Ito ay tinatawag na configuration recovery.
Para itama ang aming mga ingay na sample, probabilistikong nag-i-flip kami ng mga bit sa mga invalid na configuration batay sa average
orbital occupancy na na-average sa mga valid na configuration.
Ang mga orbital occupancy ay ang mga expectation value ng number operator na kumikilos sa bawat orbital. Ito ay tinatantya at
pinino nang self-consistently gamit ang mga estado na gawa mula sa SQD. Tingnan natin ang orbital 2 bilang halimbawa. Sa dalawa sa
apat na valid na configuration, ang orbital 2 ay occupied. Binibigyan kami nito ng inaasahang occupancy na 0.5.
Ginagawa namin ang parehong para sa iba pang tatlong orbital. Ngayon bumalik kami sa isang invalid na configuration 1 1 0. Maaari naming i-flip ang isa sa
mga bit mula 1 hanggang zero para makabuo ng valid na configuration. Ngunit alin ang dapat naming i-flip? Isang paraan ng pagpapasya ay
sa pamamagitan ng paglihis ng occupancy ng bawat orbital mula sa mga average na kinalkula namin.
Dito makikita natin na ang pinakamalaking pagkakaiba ay sa occupancy ng orbital isa. Kaya maaari nating iasahan na ang bit isa ay
dapat i-flip mula sa isa patungong zero. Siyempre, ang orbital 2 ay hindi malayo. At palaging posible, kahit gaano kaliit ang posibilidad, na
ang nasukat na estado na ito ay resulta ng maraming error sa parehong estado.
Ang pagpili lamang ng pinakamalaking paglihis mula sa mean para sa lahat ng invalid na estado ay hindi optimal. Sa halip, ang mga bit ay nai-flip
nang probabilistiko na ang posibilidad ay isang function ng mga pagkakaibang ipinapakita dito. Ipagpalagay nating sa
kasong ito nagpalit tayo ng bit na pinakamalayo mula sa average na occupancy. Kaya ang 1 1 0 ay nagiging 1 1 0 0. Gagawin natin ang
parehong proseso para sa iba pang invalid na pagpipilian. Sabihin nating sa kasong ito nag-flip tayo ng mga bit isa at tatlo.
Pagkatapos ng proseso ng pagwawasto na ito, mayroon kaming bagong set ng mga configuration na maaaring ganito ang hitsura.
Gamit ang pinong set na ito, maaari naming i-update ang average orbital occupancy para mapabuti ang fidelity. Sa aming kaso, ang bagong
occupancy ay ito.
Ang paulit-ulit na proseso ng recovery na ito ay tinitiyak na ang mga ingay na sukat ay nasasala sa mga pisikal na makabuluhang
configuration, na nagpapabuti ng katumpakan ng mga eigen state approximation sa SQD. Ang Qiskit add-on ng SQD ay may mga tool na
magiging instrumental sa prosesong ito. Kung nagawa namin ang magandang trabaho sa pag-sample ng mga estado sa support ng tunay na ground
state ng sistema, dapat ay magawa naming tingnan lamang ang mga bahagi ng Hamiltonian na kumikilos sa subspace na ito
at makakakuha pa rin ng magandang ground state at enerhiya. Sa aming napakaliit na 4 qubit na halimbawa, mayroon ding 2 o 16
posibleng estado ng sistema. Gamit ang kombinasyon ng sampling at configuration recovery, binabawasan namin ito
sa tatlong estado sa aming subspace ng interes. Tatlong estado na umaasa naming bumubuo ng support ng tunay na ground state.
I-project na natin ang aming buong Hamiltonian sa subspace na iyon. Iyon ay gumagawa kami ng matrix M mula sa column ng mga vector mula sa aming
recovered sampled na subspace at isang katulad na M dagger mula sa mga row at pinarami namin ang M dagger HM
nang pictorially. Nangangahulugan ito ng pagkuha ng mga matrix element sa mga row at column na tumutugma sa mga estado sa aming
recovered sampled subspace. Ang mga naka-highlight na row at column ay ang mga tumutugma sa aming subspace. At ang
mas madilim na naka-highlight na mga kahon kung saan sila nagtatagpo ay ang mga element na pinapanatili namin para sa aming bagong projected matrix.
Ngayon na napili namin ang subspace ng interes, maaari naming i-diagonalize ang matrix na ito sa isang klasikal na computer
gamit ang isang standard solver. Kung ang tunay na ground state ay binubuo nang buo ng mga estado sa aming subspace, ang
diagonalization na ito ay dapat magbunga ng tamang ground state at ground state energy. Kung mayroon lamang kaming karamihan ng ground state
support, maaaring malapit kami. Kapag nakuha na namin ang ground state para sa projected na Hamiltonian na ito, mayroon kaming napaka-
kapaki-pakinabang na estado mula sa kung saan makakalkula ang average occupancy ng bawat orbital.
Dati, ang aming mga occupancy ay kinalkula mula sa mga estado na na-sample namin gamit ang isang ansatz na umaasa naming makatutulong
sa amin na lumapit sa aming ground state. Ngunit walang garantiya na ang average occupancy ng bawat orbital mula sa sampling na iyon ay tumutugma sa occupancy
sa pinakamababang estado ng enerhiya. Bumalik tayo. Mayroon kaming sampling ng mga computational state. Ginamit namin ang configuration recovery
para itama ang alinman na pisikal na invalid. Pagkatapos ay kinalkula namin ang average orbital occupancy gamit ang lahat ng ito. Ang
ground state ay maaaring kasama lamang ang ilan sa kanila. Ang ground state ng projected na Hamiltonian na ito ay maaaring hindi ang tunay na ground
state ng aming orihinal na sistema, ngunit ito ang pinakamababang estado ng enerhiya na maaaring malikha gamit ang anumang superposition ng
recovered na mga estado sa aming subspace. Ang orbital occupancy ng estado na ito ay magbubunga ng enerhiyang mas mababa o katumbas ng
enerhiya ng occupancy na nakuha mula sa recovered na espasyo. Kaya ang occupancy na ito ay mas magandang pagtatantya ng aming
ground state occupancy. Maaari naming ulitin ang proseso ng configuration recovery gamit ang bagong occupancy na ito at maaari naming ulit-ulitin
ito hanggang matugunan ang aming mga pamantayan ng convergence. Ang sample-based quantum diagonalization ay mabilis kumpara sa
iba pang near-term algorithm tulad ng VQE. Ito ay mas scalable at matibay laban sa ingay at mga error sa sampling. Kailangan pa rin
nitong maghanda ng mabuting ansatz na may malaking projection sa ilalim ng support ng tunay na ground state ng aming sistema. Kung wala ni anong alam
tungkol sa aming tunay na ground state, maaaring kailangang gamitin ang SQD kasabay ng iba pang mga paraan para unang matuto tungkol sa
ground state at paulit-ulit na lumapit dito.
Ang SQD ay gumaganap ng kritikal na papel sa umuusbong na suite ng mga classical quantum hybrid algorithm at isa sa
pinakamalakas na driver patungo sa kapaki-pakinabang na quantum computing.